ich möchte heute über den 30 wenn man
noch nicht spekulieren weil wir
dazwischen noch eine etappe haben und
diese etappe heißt der sechzehnten mal
nehmen wir uns mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
wieder treffen werden dann werden wir
analysieren wo stehen wir
ist das ziel für november erreichbar und
müssen der eventuell noch weitere
maßnahmen ergreifen
das heißt wir werden jedenfalls
politisch versuchen alles zu tun damit
es auf den november beschränkt bleibt
ich kann dann nur sagen dass natürlich
ab dezember nicht sozusagen freies leben
wieder stattfindet wir das vor krone war
sondern die regeln das lüften die krone
ab all das bleibt gültig das heißt wir
müssen vorsichtig sein damit wir nicht
schnell wieder an dem punkt sind den wir
jetzt leider erreicht haben und der
nicht mehr beherrschbar ist
wenn man nicht etwas tut so deshalb tun
wir alles um das berechenbar zu machen
und wir tun jetzt ja auch sehr viel um
die wirtschaftlichen schäden
auszugleichen und über weiteres möchte
ich jetzt nicht spekulieren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren